well first i want to start by saying
uh it doesn't make sense how good this
movie turned out considering you shot it
yesterday
yeah no it is it's because we embraced
everything how crazy the world is the
world's turned upside down and we just
embraced that when we were making
lockdown we're just like the normal
rules just
aren't going to apply any of the rules
we're just going to we we
i it was starting with steve knight and
i you know on july 1 conceiving of of
writing a film set during the pandemic
and and
uh anne hathaway and chuatel edgar ford
joining the cast and
everybody everybody had
like we're all going through this
experience so i i guess
we the film turned out as good as it
turned out because like
we all had a lot to say well one of the
things is you guys are going to be the
only movie
that was made in 2020 about 2020.
yeah and it's it it is a
you know they'll be making movies about
2020 forever but you know i thought we
have the opportunity here
to make a film while we're still living
it because that will obviously color the
detailing of how the film is made and
some of it's like goofy and silly like
the fact that like
the continuity of the hand sanitizers on
on their kitchen counter
you know the number keeps going down
over the course of the film because my
crew was stealing the hand sanitizer
because
we're making the film during the
pandemic and and
that's you know hand sanitizer was at a
premium but also
i wanted to make the film quickly
because i wanted to put it out
for an audience that is still
experiencing the lockdown and and give
them a chance
to see characters they can relate to
but laugh and have fun and and have a
sense of hope for the future
well one of the things that i think is
striking about the film is that normally
when you have a two stars you know and
like when you're making a movie like
this
you will normally have such you know the
the script going to be like sort of
watered down by the time you start
filming with everyone giving input and
you know things are going to happen but
you guys i think made you feel like the
first draft
there was no time to like you know i
wanted to embrace that again like you
know you can call the
making a film under these conditions you
know a challenge or you could call it an
opportunity and i said like you know
when are we ever going to have a chance
to just shoot a first draft
and i'm going to shoot it quickly and so
you're basically seeing
the director's equivalent of a first
draft and like you know there's
it won't be watered down and it won't be
over developed and over talked about and
and
the performances will be raw and honest
because
there isn't time to sort of overthink it
i
gotta i know i'm about to run out of
time but i have to talk to you about
filming in herod's
which i thought was so great because
this is the only time you could do
something like this
can you sort of talk about what it was
like filming there and
you know uh and you know the big third
act
well you know it's the thing about
harrods is that
we like lockdown sort of grew out of the
fact that
writer steve knight and myself were sort
of locked down ourselves and we were
looking for a way out
we're like you know if we let's write a
movie and we'll get out of our homes and
and we'll let's you know it so it
started you know
it we didn't know it was gonna you know
i didn't know steve was gonna write such
a good script
that like you know it the the
aspirations for lockdown would go way
beyond just getting us out of our homes
um but you know we and we pretty quickly
settled on the idea that it was gonna be
about a heist of harrods and we
approached harrods in mid-july and and
again it's not just human beings like
you and i who are suffering from this
pandemic and being locked down
corporations are suffering harridge was
suffering
so harrods which never ever lets movies
shoot
um and if they were going to even
consider a movie would you know say like
give us a script and wait
you know three months and we'll get back
to you in this case we said there's no
script
we're only going to write the script if
you agree right now to let us shoot
there
and because of what of the pandemic
herod's did something that
was so unexpected but everything about
lockdown grew out of the unexpected
harrod said
you know you can shoot here and so
and you got to remember as a filmmaker
making i was making this film during the
pandemic i was locked down london was
locked down
so i as a filmmaker suddenly being
inside harrods which really is this
you know this box that has everything
you could ever want in it
the my personal experience walking
around the store
filming there and being told you can go
anywhere in the store and shoot anywhere
that sense of freedom i hadn't felt
since the pandemic
began personally as as a human being let
alone
the opportunity to then put it on screen
and see
these characters who are suffering from
being pooped up at home
having the chance to sort of get out and
do something really crazy and outrageous
like try to rob harrods
i already got a wrap i'm just going to
say i think people are going to really
enjoy this one
congrats and until the next one
thank you nice talking to you